I was at an event with some technology
CEOs and we were talking about what were
the most important attributes of success
in their companies and what all of them
felt was that the one thing that was not
poured well that was absolutely crucial
to success at least in their fields was
how to work well with other people
how to make people want to work with you
how to work with a team do you think
there's a way for education to get out
that I do look I have always said this
in the history of my country only two
governors of very small states have ever
been elected president a man named
Franklin Pierce the governor of New
Hampshire in 1852 who was picked just
because he was the most inoffensive
person around as we headed toward the
Civil War he was a very good man by the
way and underrated as a person but his
presidency was a failure because he
couldn't hold the country together and
me and I always told people that I
considered the fact that I was the
governor of a very small state and the
last generation part of the last
generation of Americans to grow up
without a television to be one of the
reasons that I did get elected president
we didn't get a TV till I was almost 10
years old and we didn't get a computer
till my daughter was about four years
old so I grew up in an oral culture of
storytelling and I was raised by a lot
of highly intelligent people most of
whom had very limited formal education
but they were highly intelligent and I
was taught
to listen and to observe and to pay
attention and to listen to other
people's stories I was taught that
everybody's got a story I was taught
that every life has some inherently
interesting part of it but that most
people can't get it out and if they
could get it out if everybody could tell
their story it would be interesting and
around the dinner table at my great
uncle's house for example who spent a
lot of time raising me when my my mother
was widowed by the time I was born and
my great-uncle was the smartest guy in
our family I bet his IQ was 185 and he
had like no formal education but he
could literally have you in tears in 3
minutes talking about some totally
otherwise nondescript person in our
hometown and telling the story of their
lives just laughing crying he's a genius
so before if you were a kid around the
table before you could tell a story you
had to be able to listen to one and we
would be asked the little children after
somebody told the story at at lunch or
dinner did you understand the story and
if you said yes then you would be asked
ok what did you hear after you proved
that you could listen and recount what
you'd heard then you could tell a story
but not until and I think that you can
teach people first the big fact our
differences are important they make life
interesting but since nobody is capable
of being in possession of the whole
truth about anything our common humanity
matters more so you owe everybody a
certain presumption of respect until
they do something to forfeit it and you
should be listening and
we should teach people that we should
teach people how other people view the
world differently from us how other
people have experienced life differently
from us it's a discipline it's a learned
gift and it's part of some cultures and
not part of others yeah I grew up in a
highly segregated racially segregated
southern town with a grandfather who ran
a grocery store where most of his
customers were African Americans so I
grew up knowing people that most white
kids didn't know and I learned just
nobody had to tell me I learned that
intelligence was evenly distributed
I learned that dignity was something
shared by all people I just learned that
I have no I deserved no credit for it I
was raised in a certain way I think that
all that can be taught I also think that
I agree with what you said but I think
there's another skill that needs to be
taught that you can't necessarily learn
even if you're a computer whiz or if
you're a news or a political junkie and
you read 50 blogs a day and that is how
to organize all that you know I mean one
of the reasons I'm I should be
interviewing you today one of the
reasons that I love your columns and I
love your commentary is that you help
people to synthesize things that they
know sort of that is you may write a
column or do a commentary and not state
one single fact that most of your
listeners or readers don't already know
but they haven't put it together as you
have and we live in a time where an
eight-year-old can get on the computer
and find out in third
seconds thinks I had to go to university
to learn right it's pretty scary but
it's true that doesn't mean that the
eight-year-old understands the
significance of that whatever that is in
terms of 15 other things so I think
getting along with other people is
important but I also think synthesizing
ability is important otherwise you can
take everything you read I mean just
look at what's on the news every day or
what's in the news paper is like the
political equivalent of chaos theory in
physics how do you connect the dots so I
think learning to deal with other people
and then learning to connect the dots
are the two great mega educational
skills we need to impart in every
country at every level of development
[Music]